we are back here Tekken World Tour
Finals LCQ action we got a good one it's
gonna be booked horses Puma you guys we
got hometown hero hook and I watched
earlier a huge plane gets fight spirit
yeah it has a closest match down
basically no pixel pixel the book Wanda
right there Arthur nice that week then
it turned my recent Jimmy yeah
was that a good buy I have no idea it
was it the round-robin invitation Pumas
been on a hot streak I was just out
there in Korea yeah and I was watching
this really really big eSports Tekken 7
qualifier and Puma was killing not only
like the singles competition but the 3v3
as well I saw him beat like Jade ecr's
team single-handedly a few times so he's
been playing really well okay looking
really strong right now yeah this is my
first pro this is cool bleep with me so
that means if it's booked in line that
means fighting spirit I think is out so
it's just cod looking at loser's bracket
side
book it evens out the cake if you like
he doesn't really believe in the gin the
last winners qualification match to see
looking a bit where on top 32 is gonna
lead looking like with is LCQ
I just told trunky that top there to
thin like two hours that we got 32 hey
somebody hit up huggy you said you just
said right now I don't know the Walker
once again to achieve you get the travel
potential right and you get that
experience level up opportunity overseas
right and I think you remember this
change going because he doesn't have
cheese in front of them anymore
hooks trying to stop the bleeding right
now trying to take that first round it's
a really good look right now strong
statement he's able to take it out with
radar named choice gonna take a lot of
damage though yeah damage boy I think
boo much just wants a narrow down to
potentially what makes up for the kill
you know he's gonna still have
positioning here just leave that one law
splash
round two on the board yeah the class
yeah Kyle and hometown hero back counter
it back one out of the top players are
out of the tournament right now so but
still big in the winners finals probably
the country's greatest hope of having
representatives at the top and you know
book yet you know he's been like a
staple in the finals do not have them
there is very odd yes specially after
last year right praise praise a
performance throughout the year nice
getting a read on some of you must
timing it's duck that throw right there
that's key when you're playing against
King players you mentioned earlier to
write like this except book was losing
confidence in Jin she's been messing
around with the kuma been messing around
with determined but every time he goes
back to Jin he does awesome he's giving
them hope is this winners or losers
either way long way to go for all the
players who make it out on either side
you know we got a top 32 full of just
killers killers killers the pools were
ridiculous it's easy to forget man this
is the qua bar top 30 this is like top 8
or top you know we're glad we do
this is 32 you gotta think there's 19
players that aren't in this thing that
good watching him like man I'm glad
we're not in that yeah I Howard to stay
here for Puma very good choice Kings a
cheater on the stage
gins pretty good adds to it I think it's
definitely better she's way back row
y'all but what book is definitely one of
those guys that would overcome hey
Abbott stored minus 10% wall pressure
after down back quote once again another
read on the low where you bring these
doors down interesting oh that's the
brakes on it that trying to pursue well
that was kind well that was the magic
let me show you what that spell anymore
route straight for booking just so fat
dominant I'll finally caught him tuck
any he uses that parry so well I mean I
wonder what you know questions and
doubts is did a lot of times because
he's able to provide such a unique style
he's played gin for almost forever and
he's one
that does well as successfully as he did
yeah Perry timing is crazy good and it's
not like joke like oh I'm negative
something yeah he's never overzealous
with it he always knows yeah place it
based on the player soars up to soars up
there - yeah - big mistakes right here
you could have even it up but he does
have her age give him a chance to steal
this round wall position - oh there it
is pressure off the wall not quite there
yet there it is how do I know if you
want to do that that looks shake weird
yeah everybody's looking shaky isn't one
for a mixer button here which is just
killed straight up the toefl finds
himself on set point here another low
parry the wall ootek catch catches him
in the back nice job center stage oh
nice Oh God
oh I can't believe that habits both
layers but final-round situation set
point for book here what a comeback for
Puma home meet
oh my god
nice tech trap yes thank God it put the
kills that encounter was it was that
what you try to parry miss time that is
unfortunate I don't know about that's
what you want after like a very very
intense match like that was reminded
about my Thai massage you walk to the
door she beat you in some block if that
was their first baby don't take role
they'll tell you in the tack oh man that
was rough for book I mean those totals
match both ways I mean he had sold me
round you know you had such huge lead
yeah a lot of mistakes front book that
second game up and down back and forth
round maybe over Delta close it out
you know one thing I know stupa hasn't
done really any tools no no that's not
his style or whatnot but I mean he's
always going for the mix-up to put books
timing on the crouches it's just forcing
poom in a second-guess himself be sharp
as long as it doesn't make mistakes I
think it's papers game most of its
damages come from what just made some
wall pressure in wall he's right between
the tugs and all the Perry's ibooks
throwing out I think it's really making
Puma second-guess himself every decision
that he has to make you know that last
game even though a lot of states I think
you recognized I was all on him it's
cowboy Jose Lopez real safe with the
Capo's he notice how he's getting high
wall flats but he's not going for that
extra head he's not being too greedy
he's already up and he knows that he's
making a lot of mistakes to dropping
coppers
burn oh goodness
Oh anyone's game nice knob submit his
tracks go while one round away this tied
crowd starting to look alive now you
believe ring zero parry
this is not over yet
moving right back in it and the only
person clapping - Chanel fight but it's
aggressively loud trying to close it out
this time can you get it done rage now
for Puma the last chance oh this is this
is gonna be a hard on pool and he rinsed
it off close it out he thought he was
gonna tuck the throw attempt yeah you
risked it all on that one mixup and
that's gonna be that good job though
hook going on and now Pumas gonna be in
the ludus so he's not out yet definitely
I like the option that he had at the end
there you know he went for the launcher
I think one of his good tricks and
especially since book has been ducking
and every time he went into the spin he
would catch him with the mid elbow so
the way that I was playing out it looked
like book was just you know content on
just ducking a lot of time is forcing
Puma to go mid and he fell for the trap
there's a lot of hugs going on right now
and there I feel it man like I said a
lot of type players
I've been watching all day I've been
falling in this in the bracket and look
we all know he was the best player in
Thailand always down to represent and
I'm really glad
he's having to showing me when
winterside yeah after what after what's
been kind of an inconsistent year for
him too right
he's kind of struggled with to produce
the same results that he produced last
year that we got kind of familiar with
be able to get I'll just take the winner
sides after fall good and here we go
round one to this top 32 yo right up the
back miss SOT yeah Jeff Mishima was the
man earlier that said girl andhe last
year's LCQ winner it's a losers in the
second round I'm one round right now on
a teeth but yeah everybody kind of has
their eyes no jet Bhishma where did you
come from the Philippines that's what I
recognized that that was the flag is
helping you out thanks Rick you have to
question listen I've never seen any
Akuma player use that move never open
when they use at the same time that was
crazy
forth the teeth but huge favorite here
or a heavy favorite I should say yeah I
think a lot of people had them use
either him the John what are the
Pakistani players as favorites here uh
costumes as well right now Nisha put the
one in control here though yeah you
would have thought that like this he
flooded like two packs that players
would have had the most experienced
Akuma in the mirror man yeah but it's
style change up as well right true I
think those little things those are the
fuse can make a big difference
especially in circles early on hold that
dock
or for dishing with the book for super
accounting it right that's such a big
lead here 20 seconds all goodness yeah
as soon as you said it's not done not
done
drop the grumbles oh I think is
guaranteed right there
oh man police drop in future cop Oh fun
yeah there's some crucial drops there
you don't want to let him live
okay name Swapnil now we got the names
all right so the teapots wanted to leave
and he just lost the round Jenny looks
like he's about to win this one there we
go nice TV
the word point is she for my team
players yeah I mean you talk about that
going into movie like last month of
competitive play for this game right the
difference between watching a teapot
watching honey and then watching the
humans that we've seen up until now
yeah it's with punishing off wish with
punishment and optimization off those
with punishes right I mean if they if
they let damage go it's rare yeah like
the meet like their meter actually
converts damage not the drops
fortunately it's an important part for
the character of course aim to and this
is the remember this is a top 32 winners
so the winner of this will move on to I
believe around top 16 saves different
stage get Mishima selection choice not
sure why
round one maybe just like a fight
back to the table here it's like a it's
like a Doge in with the large music yes
I like this much better actually
I see and you see the difference in
there's a lot of whips coming from
Archie put and Jeff achievement didn't
capitalize on it where I think in the
opposite situation that's where I keep
but would oh yeah Geoff more focusing
I'm just trying to move away right just
emphasizing back that's not really
trying to punish it for those lists yeah
super cool box where it gets dicey right
in at 4:44 range
[Music]
no very good to use in the classroom
that looks a little bit lost that around
he was just a bit too passive not really
throwing out a lot of diversity with his
attacks just kind of he said while he's
backing up facing out waiting to get
killed he essentially
- did you set just like that and that's
unfortunately he had to burn that meet
her there yeah didn't get a lot of
return he had the position but they did
just like that is gone and then a jab
flow from a team he's got the meter yeah
the meter of management is both in this
match it's gonna be hard for players you
let me as soon as you use that meter you
have to or something like that he use
the back one the anti air jet machine
out of the DB flip that's one of the
signs of just having so much experience
with the matchup you don't see a lot of
players doing that anticipation and we
actually showing off some tricks going
to look for that
ah you went for the Tatsu you had the
media too - he couldn't FA DC fireball
but instead one for the tattoo and
that's going to be punished and maybe
once you want to winter side Jeb Mishima
nice showing no play fortunately he'll
be the loser side of our top 32
the bracket right now don't wory it hold
for I believe I think I think it might
be poor forever this one here are the
John atif and cousin Kershaw a costume
going up against John ding right now man
John did look pretty good today he has
but this is gonna be a gauge test this
is where the real tournament starts yes
right here
and don't forget like him at match
events this year John ding he got a 9th
place every single time he had 5 9 place
masters finishes this year nothing
higher attended like how book was always
the 5 5 5 5 guy yes Jonathan 9 9 9 guy
is that how you laughing Korean 9 it was
Julia I think he's done
round 1 of the turf that's it a lot
bigger promise maybe when you're asked
to but he said Julia is like a costume
most notably it's just short of top 8
than that dubai master event really
strong performance there overall but
right off the bat here down 4-2 gonna
take talking to the wall put it in this
corner such an unusual rip from Donnie
early there and now the range art
attempt gonna get out of corner of
course I mean happen funny yeah I think
Johnny has like the worst hit ratio on
radar thought of any competitor for
everything every time he doesn't with
his backs to the wall you have to know
it's it's not even gonna block
no parts the doubt for two
oh the world
and customers really dude he's throwing
a really big mixers scarecrow fans
amantha stances understanding normal
taxable oh yeah got a little greedy
there he went for an uppercut whoa Eddie
was enhanced and there's the lodge
I'm digging officially in the lead on
the set early in the set floated okay
with that got away with nice patience
from Jun ding that's what you need you
can't rush into things especially if
you're not even sure you're gonna hit
the character or not better off just
being a bit more patient learning which
moves our best to knock her out she
dances whether it be a low stance some
others I think is fine with taking low
post I want to get hit with a bridge our
race drive or or counter hit low get
launched times winding down times on
jumping side loading here picked out
board one this to the managers take the
damage boss I mean I knew that drivers
coming before I can't believe what
approaching that's yeah that was the
surprise you're supposed to block but I
guess we just wanted to throw throw
jumping off giving give a little testing
test
both players are yeah I mean they're
both utilizing the great food that both
of their characters have to offset
built-in yeah I've seen that happen a
lot of lot of players trying to
challenge that straight up not really
knowing that you know if they commit to
the second third hit that they leave
themselves open yeah I don't really have
to stick your neck out like this that's
great you're so nice too because every
hit is accounting hit launch every
single part of that string perspective
especially when you're up first
going downstairs finally really turn
things around you offset time to get
that two out the one leads with God nice
block again tonic filaments pretty great
and off started with him just going all
in with the string out of the handstand
yeah he just to copy image that was a
crazy comeback that was impressive
you definitely sets the press at some
point to a sense of desperation I think
he ever closing out on costumes time he
was definitely speaking with some jabs
in down for once that was kind of
quashed and a questionable range as well
yeah and it's probably active a costume
the previous round stop stop the rage
drive
yeah especially when Tom was on his side
it didn't make say it didn't make sense
I mean that situation though against
Eddie Eddie's gonna run up and force the
race drive anyway so you can't really
run away from them but Dafina does have
great movement so he had so many chance
to close John Dean yeah he was down to
one hit you said yourself big trouble
when you found that pixel I mean chances
are very very
and you don't start believing the
comebacks real until like the third or
fourth hey where's that he might do this
did you really don't start believing the
comeback happens until they actually
come back and say hey I was supposed to
happen like that well that was a great
pleasure timing definitely doubted at
the top of appropriate funding convert
so
right there would be number two if you
get a little low poking
that was just ran straight oh my
goodness opportunity and daunting takes
it round two easier that's easier now
it's easier that way you have bigger
feet they meet the the gesturing window
like three frames longer maybe you drop
too many times yeah I mean that
definitely shows up there's definitely
some nerves here get that that's it
that's me that's mental part that's a
clear sign but lots of faithful pulling
it back again some good lead here at
grouchy and nervous doesn't mean that
you're gonna lose just means that you're
not playing up to what you normally pay
before that was counter hit and didn't
really follow through don't jinx jinx
I'm not trying to they said no way right
this is what custom has to do so the
match down a little bit to establish
more control it's time trade in his
favor of course he could carry here just
short of the wall but you give a whole
price
a little bit too risky if you find
especially not sure how to do that wall
combo if there is you even is that was
such a hard block
it's getting a lot of mileage out of
that one yeah yes the third time that's
it now wait for this k12 yeah just a
choice to choose this page of option big
opportunity for judging combo plus mix
ups to follow you could do it defense
now especially with no walls just on boy
yeah that's the perfect space right
there spacing and patience John degan
look so so good today and I think that's
a a good confidence boost for him
staying in the winner side and you know
but he pointed one of the big threats
into the loser's bracket
oh good next yeah here we go
Jotaro from Japan corner gets rocks
dragons I musician I'm magician whatever
the hell's that
[Laughter]
Yoshimitsu
interesting choices we know Jotaro is
made but I've never seen me he's been
running meeting up against certain
Cornish you know one of the questions
that you asked when I get when a player
switches office mains is is he gonna be
able to pursue key ready for situations
like that that require you to have some
specific character knowledge he might
have tried knock down gaze down a game
I'm sure he did but that was just really
good play by Jotaro for just knowing the
right thing to do with negan in that
situation especially since I've never
seen abusers character I saw I saw
really good I mean they're pretty
similar in strength you know with Loftus
having that big long range and vegan
range consists of a turn
and of course intimidation stance the
threat that that represents in neutral
right now man I musician I Spit on the
inside go in rage the car looks pretty
clean hit the close it out
[Music]
it's already good the intern poach out
by the way
oh yeah many didn't work when the
Wednesday dojo the men in the house yeah
that's still a crazy run when you think
about it man sane that's good you know
you might have catalysis that was his
best tournament performance ever you
know I mean yeah the competition was
stacked yeah as far as competition goes
you know he's won regional tournaments
major tournaments but this one had all
the names there and he took them all out
beautiful like take' st. again back to
back the back and then there's one more
- there was another one
I mean shadow I mean there's like it
felt like he's the reason why talkies
not really does love these imitations I
like I like that man about to launch
don't turn your back to me that's not
cool not cool - I'll take this 50%
Chapman okie yeah Sam for showing the
flash now so much labor rules guaranteed
block oppose like that it's hard to
gauge how much life you actually lost as
they reset the ball
just looking for any opening able to
close out the segment he knows he just
needs one yeah whoa easy they usually
got caught with that race drive setup
you know just being well variation will
even it up here putting this up in a
rage smart play by musician choose a
rage driver like that one plus two or
something like that
hey George Howell city let you try to
just punch oh yeah
[Music]
Wow I like that just walk up still super
duper patient and it's big contrast the
way that he plays doctor is just go soon
I couldn't help us bring that suit yeah
this goes in it's crazy you know if you
have a clear distinct style between two
different characters then you have a
real like different you know yeah a real
different balance to what you doing what
you like useful it's a sense to he can
definitely tell that I music isn't all
too familiar with this metacharacter
matchup as well yeah you show it back
though right now oh my God he's gonna
win he's catching him with that that's
the final final round here with Oh
counter head this is big so unfortunate
five he's is you can - 15 yeah - make
his way back
this could be paper interpreters are all
right magician time yeah I know I'm just
waiting on it you know for some viral
Yoshi Oh into the drive immediately
here it comes I'm musician what's he got
ok so it goes down the wire
what's he got oh the throw oh I'm
musician with the crazy comeback final
final round gets it done stays on the
winter side of the bracket here in the
Le through so many different attacks at
Jotaro that Joe Tom was not able to
recognize deductible string and just let
him get away with money and cost him
everything there you make you made the
perfect Twitter clip and it started
happening oh man look at this we got
booked for the Jojen boy right this is
actually awesome ok got it
lewis of your head cheesecake is dep
mean the issue with this man chose a new
just has so many just like you know long
start up attacks that they're very easy
to pair off if you're if you're you know
all boy
I mean don't forget though we just saw
you can boy beat run a black earlier in
this tournament
that's your
it was a good match - I will say run a
black close actually showed that he was
very knowledgeable with the matchup a
lot of Perry's a lot of clutch parries
and I would say that book is on that
level if not one more level up exactly
run a black with just tournament
experience and the consistency looks
definitely rock solid with the yeah this
year for him has been great
he's been playing so well throughout
every time he said I consider him an
x-factor in every event he enters
because you know he's down to take out a
big name or two that's sure it's not
even so much about what he gets for
himself it's about ruining the
tournament brother yeah as long as
you're not in his path you like alright
yes I'm glad he answered yes well the
few players that utilize that Vegas
right just within Japanese oh wait
still arrangements being a protective
down to while standing one also a safe
need me right
ports no dropping cop out of the jab Wow
there we go that was a whip horn he was
looking for anything at that range the
whole time Oh same situation as last
about it
okay man he was expecting the power cuts
but he just reacted nothing hey you know
yo gym boy he's doing down street but
he's not finishing that drink you might
be scared at the you know hook trying to
marry you Deb it's it's Marty worse than
kick his his favor it makes the other
guy question whether books punish you
know he's twenty fourth times but it's
only wall set for now
I loved your boy uses that jab
recognizing that just the best yeah yeah
obscene has a very high damage potential
behind it
Spacey as well but get the action
connect again cut a break you didn't get
the ocean it does instead how to counter
it opportunity I respect this final
round Game one because of it does that
even launch that's that's a jack that's
a jack
interrupts the fourth what you attempt
no fish you're gonna catch this down -
no I hold this wall I think of it is
your voice using that jab which people
at that space with it where that down
come boy big boy common whoa that was
the only command graph of the entire
game yeah saved it right board needs at
the wall where the damage potential is
at its highest it caught him was he
caught them in the middle of a string I
don't even know but get a chance to
break it because when you get caught in
the stream while you're like pressing 1
or 2 and they throw you all that I hate
that moment gum like I broke it but
you're lucky I was mashing that's
actually what's I what you mentioned
earlier that's what's so fun to watch
about yo gym boy play for me he
showcases the power of one movie just
the power of jab yeah how to use your
jabs in this game and I mean you don't
use the character specialist I don't I
don't even know if he's ever played
taken without gigas I don't know I don't
know I feel like he only came into
existence was created yeah he was
created shot guys
[Laughter]
we didn't see a lot of Perry's from
look-back game he started off very very
sluggish was almost able to steal the
gameplay he attempted a pair yeah hold
it out right off the bat early on here
he's already at set the - I mean yo
Jimmy in the desert jabs now board once
okay Harry something it doesn't want to
throw down attached not sure what's he
gonna get mad forget the pickup not
gonna kill Susie a McDuffie or candy oh
boy that was unfortunate gummy wall
splat it's gone - I think that tonk now
crush - gigas is kind of setting the
tone for this match just a little bit
more faster just wants to not really
predict ain't getting punished too much
from that talk oh boy what's the right
answer for that string what's into the
wall the horses the whole this pressure
because patients with Yoji boy Perry
lrk finally guys need that he need good
timing
then laid the streets you see what time
is the movie let's do something fun
like you know
right back at you
oh my goodness he took so much to the
face
that's way where's the helmet broke at
this time he's gonna crack for us with
the race drive or you see book jump into
light you just want to deal with that
ratio I know it's supposed to hit but
like isn't everything but you know I
think a lot of that had to do with the
stage joystick right because there
wasn't much room for or yugi-boy to move
around and book also yeah on the other
side cut [ __ ] out a lot of damage the
stone wall scenarios yeah the entire
game station like here will be very big
praying to the to the stage select
algorithm I think this is more of a
moment of thinking about the match
rather stage a lot about what kind of
adjustments he wants to come the table
you gotta do that slow down the set why
he lost and how he won the first game
that's putting it together he needs to
find the right answers right here right
now he chose the Forgotten realm
interesting choice he must have you know
I mean obviously giggy's get some crazy
damage off his mama's fish with the
floor breaks cuz he has a ton of moves
at spy floor breaks right now
playing off stream right now hopefully
we have time know round one flip it back
into time
good parry that time yeah like you meant
to Ricky not the stuff the attacks using
boys I'm using just like jabs outboard
once it does little phrase
that's true here that parent jump back
to trying to avoid the guards gonna put
you and I guess yeah and so frustrated
to approach chicas like trees using that
power question yeah but I feel like the
more you use it unless you know
successful or the less chance you
haven't being a successful because
you're giving book more opportunities to
prepare himself set himself up to maybe
go low or throw like you said yeah kind
of the more you use before its eyes we
trying to see that start on e what
sweeping a lot and you just don't fit
ductile all right it's got cop a lot of
the act cakes definitely the grab seven
seconds for before you block down okay
just the brick
big opportunity is very very close
anymore spike boy
but it's one round away from moving on
to top 16 winterside I'll be so crazy
that's a launcher on this stage in this
stage normally oh my god to the penile
wall staff and Apple two one four here
we go we applied another one Oh shifted
which he could've kept it's like yeah
but like I said earlier books going say
frog on his compost he's dropping a lot
to be here he's got a big lead here
trying to slows it out after all the
winner side of the bracket should get
too excited too because you know he's
got a long way to go yeah Yoshi boy
obviously you don't fit he's such an
emotional player he wants to win but he
else recognizes and look at this again
verse zero don't forget definitely bias
with this no clue
that's the fanboy I'm just a family once
had a long year he got sponsored midway
through the season really really good
sponsor illiquid and he almost made it
all you know he took it to the very last
event at Dreamhack earn a lot of points
put himself at ball by position but just
a little bit too late' yeah too
competitive this year but here he is the
LCQ yeah you know it's just like for
someone that's been out of the
tournament see like you know he would
jump into yeah various time you in there
but not really serious and then he just
came back and just came back with a fire
like this it was a slow startup it took
maybe about a month or two for him to
really get back into this right but even
kind of quietly just had some really
good success just lack that big
performance that big win to be able to
punch his ticket right ya know he's
young so he's got school and other
things first
take care before he gets into the games
he's back he's focused going up against
one of Pakistan's finest right here and
here trying to create this upset Oh God
clutch shout was a great punish
I spoke with Jay TCR he feels like here
is probably one of the top two or three
the whole tournament yeah q I mean okay
okay oh man Santa wait for Ken can he do
it small stage one is the big trick I
mean we some we just saw one Pakistan
player fall to the losers will just be
number two you talk about bracket X
Factor's a lot of people look again you
were looking at the John to be able to
make them at least winterside top eight
right this will be an upset I beat it
comes again he's gambling with the
slides nice blocking even on life oh
don't drop unbelievable get sense here
it down to loser bracket let's go let's
go liquid huh matchups are starting to
happen we're starting to see some Titans
clash right now everyone was saying you
know Pakistan you know like everyone of
course what people forget there's still
people you know every country's still
getting better and obviously you know
everyone wants to showcase that they're
the best against doing a great thing
that people are forgetting to is that
you know Japan and Korea obviously will
do it like on top of the world for so
long they finally have like a reason to
have a fire little to finally try and
get be motivate to try to push
themselves even harder than before
oh yeah sure yeah and don't forget guys
combo with the huge sail huge shout-outs
course for sponsoring the twt year after
year you still got this crazy on the
ages plus hitting us some crazy back
back there no bows attached sorry what's
the update yeah it's crazy sure they
could do it if you wanted to and still
got the drone available to for a
discounted price check him out qualms
with us a.com hey man that combo was
actually the crazy discount the backpack
in the snow it was there's some things
put a ridiculous deal you don't want
just carry your stick around on your arm
the whole tournament you definitely have
a a sick bag and that bag is just made
perfectly for I just see everybody's got
one
oh my goodness well we got take a short
break guys when we come back the LCQ is
gonna continue it in the top 32 matches
getting crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is gonna be very interesting both
players as you said have multiple
characters in their arsenal so let's see
what they went with and let's see what
kind of strategies they apply but this
again we're switching back to two out of
three okay Eli's a rare - this is a
first - - as you said and I think you
know this is gonna be a very interesting
matchup without the ability to sidestep
away from those diet kicks and that
pressure the drive kicks and the
fireballs are gonna play a huge part in
how this is gonna work out and if you've
been watching rank qu all day he
utilizes that low PAH from the bear all
the time and if you've been watching
Chanel all day he's constantly low
crushing with that dive kick so we'll
see if those two moons
you know how they interact okay Wow
Perry out of bear stance
oh yeah oh he dropped it oh he's doing
the bear dives of his own but miss input
they're not looking good that wrong does
you rip guard very nice see you gotta
take what that's given to you if he
makes those mistakes you've got to be
ready to whip one - and wrong - was
ready he was on point okay I mean you
gotta be I feel like if you're a bear
player you have to have insane reflexes
of course yes optimize what's given to
you okay two hits and he gets it
that's that low PAH you know that that
low dive kick is gonna be dealing with
that in no time
oh yeah okay uppercut the mix-up
and the follow-up what's gonna happen
here okay honey bear stands up that was
another mistake punish it no out the
mix-up here again that's great defense
there from wrong to able to kind of
mitigate the situation they're not be
put into danger but look he's looking to
close it out this could be it
no he missed the wall messed him up her
only option to beat a stand block off of
that - is a low that's very unsafe and
unblockable that's very slow so he's
taking the safe bet stand blocking that
mix-up yeah now the question is when is
Chanel gonna resort to the riskier
options that will beat the stands well
the thing is right now options bars he
doesn't have anything left regarding
meters so he's gonna have to play this
one pretty honestly here yes and rank
you just looking so good not having to
worry about that meter as you said
building a lead already in this game
round three and look at these spacing
just using the standing jabbing cutting
him off like down forward to using this
sparingly using the down back to as well
it's just been working out everything is
looking good for wrong too yes and look
you know so interesting to consider
everything we've seen today wrong shoe
not picking Panda against me happy to
pick panda against Chanel and look how
great he's doing well he's doing really
good right now but you know eventually
he's gonna have to face that same FIFO
earlier hello still stand blocking he
used his meter but he's about to build
another one and he has rage oh yes
beautiful work there are three rounds to
none against Chanel right that is quite
the statement I would say modern fire on
fire yeah now you know what in you know
his Eliza has been for the most part
uncontested throughout the entire
tournament yes you're right
such a ferocious opponent
just shows rank choose level yeah but
you know again this is actually true his
true main character Alisa you're right
he's definitely gonna know what tools he
needs to use in this matchup the most
experience he has with any of the
characters tournament wise legacy
character Alisa and that's the thing too
now he's able to move more freely I
would say oh yeah and he'll be able to
be able to kind of I guess get around
the Panda stuff man look at that combo
to his jet pack action mix-ups
wow that's the clutch out but it gets
hop kick in the wall here has another
opportunity to shine but the punish
there I mean you've gotta go for those
mix-ups right the the head or the
shoeshine yep Rancho is doing such a
great job of Stan blocking most of the
time but reading the lows when they come
okay second hit ducks under that's the
thing wrong she thought he had a hit
there but he committed and Chanel able
to punish there with a dark counter hit
g-clef yeah and of course that being
guaranteed on the counter hit jab nice
combo at the wall okay he's just
stalking him a giant bear going after
the robot yeah and keep in mind this is
two out of three I mean this is Oh
lookey one-sided right now ranked you're
looking so confident and the clutch here
right now it's gonna have to fail oh my
gosh he just went it's gonna be six
rounds straight collision el it could be
an you know this is from Panda yes six
rounds straight from one of the lowest
tier characters in the game yeah and
again proves just how well kept yeah
well in this game
interplay obviously it's the key
component to the game's design okay what
for the jumping attack able to float him
out of there gets a conversion here not
able to get the last hit though and he's
so confident being at point-blank range
it's so rare to see that in a tournament
setting someone so brave to be in the
danger zone like that at all times
look at that he constantly is moving in
he doesn't want to be far away he wants
to be close yeah and here we go
chainsaws are out but man he's in red
too if he gets a launcher it could be
all over for him he's
oh what a block what the wrong punish ya
coulda got to launch there oh my god not
yet it's not over yet for the robots
this is outrageous
Frank you not giving up but he got the
block very nice
he's been pressing that mix-up the
jumping low into the bear castle jumping
nothing is so scary and this is that
destroyed okay letting the clutch now
whilst [ __ ] down have what it takes
will chanel be able to even it up
because this is huge it's tournament
life on the line here this is gonna be
the difference between placing in our
top four and then going on to be able to
play some top three Wow okay oh man what
a beefy punish I love what I'm seeing
here from rank ooh look so solid as I'm
back to the wall here and you would
think this is a good position for Chanel
but it's so scary considering how much
my PS chainsaws out backing up Wow man
what a win during active hitbox with
those chainsaws the belly-flop Wow and
it's simple as that ranked your moves on
decisive victory against Janelle
whoo welcome back everyone
take a world tour finals 1:1 kagemaru
versus the John
are you serious 1:1 kagemaru man this
guy has been on a tear today Pakistani
Slayer yeah you know he's always the
kind of player that's like it has that
one tournament where it's like amazing
and this could be in a wild card player
right and can show up in any mode given
moment and to give a day I'm gonna just
put the bracket on its ass right I mean
Paxton they've been falling right now
like what's happening well we got hob
kick so much talent here man
this is and this is a big one here for
tomorrow if he can beat the John that's
gonna be a huge hoppity boost for cities
ready what a whip on is something twice
in like two seconds right there dude -
lets went back for it kagemaru up on the
John right now tomorrow took the first
game the John came back strong taking
game number two lock or score - hey
sliding low or more uh uh-huh
Wow yeah just pushing to John with that
couch - good try though good work Shawn
Wow
now for a oneness with punish here yeah
hey what characteristic cop did you felt
like just felt like it was a hell marry
there knew John was ready to punish I
easily like this is winter side to
bracket top thirty twos but Crazy's
already yeah you know this Nepalese one
plant no one said had a chance to win
kagemaru no one no one talked about God
about what he did it man too many people
dear man yeah he got lost in the shuffle
he's one of the most clutch players and
tournament survivors right one like when
he went through the whole team set point
no way step right corrected as punished
that time so on point against this mark
right now yeah I mean it's kind of like
what happened when Pakistan first came
to the scene they were underestimated
nobody really could do it off yeah heavy
favorites it now Kaka Maru is being
overlooked that he's like yo guys think
about me first
yeah don't forget about me hello
Pakistan's like Japanese cargo mark
tapping the stepping low we punish oh
you could take it can you kill here Maru
that's a big shake-up dude you bottom
side of that Brack everyone was talking
about you three pack Templars just went
through the bracket right everybody
we're talking about it John
this weekend another one and losers you
and I need to stop this bracket is why
this [ __ ] is wide open oh there's no way
we have no idea who's a man who has any
any child and speaking of which you
still got your tech awards or 2017
champion still in it mm-hmm oh yeah
versus Peter gift the whole store it's
like you know what the herds and LCQ I'm
just gonna end of that one yeah I mean
to get my spot there you know obviously
you had that really big win earlier this
year in Saudi Arabia where ya supposed
to be supposed to be a big-money
tournament never got that way but now
he's back here to the cheetah Vicki
right off the bat put these electrics on
you're gonna put pickles at the wall
that go staying true to the geese play
earlier so god of today and watching
futons I was like this is classic food
on like it's not okay it feels like he's
playing on points of sick it wasn't
earlier in the year cut uh yeah look I
mean I don't know yet but it looks like
he's still in winter sighs man yeah
that's what John dingos like today too
and everyone came prepared for
tournaments followed up by some stinkers
I mean started off what this masters run
into Korea right place every which I
mean I think a lot of people were
considered that an upset
hasn't been able to be as consistent
like you said but man he's definitely
shown that he can turn it up on a given
tournament right get in the first round
here yet food on a lot of doubt board
ones out of peco's he looks close up for
fours
nobody's really taking a risk of
sterling we see a lot of neutral a lot
of space and I she's waiting for the
first opening I think we're a long set
nicely to float launched in old man she
wins on the close it out one of those
leagues where maybe kudos just still has
much even though you never quite is
hella GISA it's throughout season too
good makes up just that's the blow jabs
down for once exhaust anyone slowly push
food on sports this wall
come on through the slight sidestep flat
feet which are trying to get off of it
you're gonna lose the first game I think
you know who does I'm sure would rather
just go down fighting with at least one
or two rounds on herself
yeah still kind of just in the download
phase right now that's the first big
risk
hopefully now he's pressing scary part
is pickles now has it took him a long
time to get there yeah it's a rarity to
Maximo that's how they count them real I
[Music]
look at this fresh from peco's right now
see a downpour coming from done I see an
electric coming like you said the
control in that last round was I mean
you talked about his movement up until
that point it was about safe-ish
pressure jabs down point one but then
back fashion utilizing his movement be
able to create those wait for Nash
opportunities which opened up for that
round oh yeah lots of sidestep left out
up yeah that goes there and that's the
way one time it's just his overall
general playstyle he's not really known
for being the most aggressive and setup
heavy character he's just a rock-solid
always and he's always gonna play his
game no matter what and that's kind of a
no pet goes for
here we go going to Devil's pit this
time around he's banging on his heart
checking to see if is still running okay
okay he's got to get a kick start
running it's not powered up yet must be
iron
hesitate we saw that whip their party
really do it like I feel like like much
money would still electric turn right a
spot that's marked by Pecos going with a
hike rushing loath to put it what you
want to do against ischemic arrogance in
general just that you can avoid dealing
with the electric you know knowing that
your lows are always gonna go under
electric if they ever do all three of
pieces low posts kind of go under highs
it just works out for that's why we
probably not seen could on split up too
many electrics out he's already kind of
it stopped
yes I believe higher emphasis on Japs
amid in the mid fish does give to down
30 pressure is on the pressure is on who
does gotta fight now that looked like
season one kudos right there with a
[Music]
porno you only need one time blow them
to sleep let them think that is free all
day round three
fight okay trying to go for that wall
bounce
now Ford won battles all day I some
liver petals all day don't you want to
do against Russia clothes are adding up
very interesting nauseating very patient
but behind you right now a roundel well
there's the electric and if your pet
host you died with two meters that's
like it that's what that's so much time
invested gone it's like a geese
violation mochi is your old site that
left its kind of tired during the game
to be damaged anyone has ever hit up
born their life I've never seen a peach
color face this cool got to be different
everybody's rocking the white
dumb I hear it helps with your nerves
they were a quick yeah but of course
choose some gum while she plays I know
that's where a fact tournament I'm so
fortunate definitely always one of my
favorites she's really good at
representing the u.s. man just so solid
even in the big tournaments who never
really falters under pressure like the
guy do stop by you yeah yeah I watched
the first set at me I felt like she was
gonna take in the way she started off
you know you as a legend don't know that
he's placed top three ready Evo in the
past before these guys have so a lot of
history yeah it's been a while but round
one said legacy players man white all
right here we go final game
picking up right where we left off just
on dope a necklace working its way in
the mid-range here working those jabs
this new attack Nietzsche pins on it
really helps out eats on the infinite
stages right he doesn't really give up
much damage as a result
would be the smart thing did a little
committal as possible it's also many
ones that got the meter that was a
pat-down Ford one how'd it come out like
a couple frames later buddy got launched
man they're so annoying too because also
Kinkos is keeping a fair balance of the
mid and high attacks just in case you
don't want to throw it up for four go
for those low flushes and try those out
he probably gets loaded holding on to
his meter because he hasn't found any
opportunity really to use it he has
ignored for fact three shoes at all
really outside of the first he surprised
how sweet
we're the only reason some o2 bars to
look that gate walk off load and there
are the longest days he tried to call
out there to round set point for him now
fight for peco's no gauge though done
the whole fashion way
like Anakin set right the chaff pressure
mixing that out yeah me now put on so
stared too far in the upward Wars it's
kind of forcing him to play the exact
same way to limit it now that just his
small folks can't afford to drop this
note right here goes for the simple
version he'll sweep out just about to
say to look like it he was getting up
close for it he's a control okay here we
go
final final round pepper persecute us
play on the winter back what a clutch
jab to be able to pull about that yeah
they're both doing the same thing each
other the jab does down for one to keep
them out of the air because both of the
low pressures are more of your big
threats the next one should be can't
press this luck too many times I like to
keep out perfect choice right here and
goes over coup darwin's nicely done
panco saying all the winners not because
I'm still in the tournament but now on
Lu the side of course she's got a win to
turn to the right it doesn't matter you
up the widow's lose aside if you win the
tournament you're in the finals tomorrow
that is probably the best thing you
could have done that's like a dream
I don't somebody's dreams is about to
come true today
they get to bypass a whole years worth
of travel complication come here and
fight in one of the hardest tournaments
of all time yeah it is no doubt about
earlier was talking about how like
there's something different but this LCQ
incompatible years pass and there's
something about I don't know what it is
man but it is that I think what it is is
that there is so much representation
from all across the world at this
tournament America Europe even I mean
Pakistan yeah I mean everybody that
plays Tekken is here I mean it really
does feel like it has a different level
of prestige it's coming it's come into
that is what's really cool about it like
you said the representation right
there's so many nationalities
represented here and it's like it's
finally there's something bust is either
right there putting like real players it
is everybody that entered felt like they
had a chance to win a tournament and
from the very first round we saw high
quality matches it wasn't like your
ordinary major back home in the States
for example with we're watching guys get
weeded out the tournaments but from the
very beginning we saw people fall like I
looked at the brackets I don't want to
put you on a spot or anything but I know
you had a rough day
yeah it's all I can think is here both
hello good oh oh oh my god this is loser
bracket estimates of the John versus
doujin about Stanford the Philippine I
think about it like this right
Oh Japan we saw like the grand finals
between the Philippines and Pakistan
that's where it start in Japan in Japan
and today and today it feels like every
like Japan is like hey remember us look
we're still kind of good it's so cool
you and you and Anakin rip mentioned
this before we went to break I feel like
this year is since the eve of Japan
started we've been so razor focused on
the rise of Pakistan and obviously arson
ash was the the one who started to spin
that wheel right but what am i for what
I'm really excited for is seeing
everyone else's response to that exact
things that you're so used to seeing me
low highs all those players be the guys
that make other people look like they
don't know what they're doing in them
right but then when they finally run
into someone that forces an evolution
out of them that's what I'm looking
forward to seeing what is your answer
exactly when you saw didn't Dubai with
low high specificity yo wait a second lo
I did some homework here the leveling up
these guys going home is going to
qualify to top a break it a lot of times
people judge you based on your last
tournament result like it's the most
recent one that only matters and so
since Pakistan has been on such a tear
lately they've been only winning and
winning winning what has done is added a
lot more pressure on these guys to
continue winning otherwise people are
gonna view them as like oh they're
falling off and but I mean all it is is
just everybody's good it was just it was
just a hot streak and have the scales I
think are kind of balance
people thought they were just on another
level or exactly this is just taking
them serious yeah we we got him we got
to be more serious about how we look at
Paxton doesn't tell you the washed up
[Laughter]
chop on the ground here
stand up yellow from the John with
players like him I mean it's to another
point when Adam Anakin was talking about
to these players some of them aren't as
well-traveled as high as possible that
being able play playing stay just like
this playing on streams like this hit up
until now we haven't seen that affect
them and give them you know have nerves
for that but when everyone else has been
putting them under a magnifying glass
because of those sense don't mean to cut
you off but he hit a little bit don't
use like your shadow hit the shoulder
real quick
allow these guys I think it's the first
time we're seeing them step outside of
their home country and fight in
international competition we talked
about a lot it's different you know
having to stick on your lap as opposed
to are capable to talk about a Japanese
and Korean players come to America
struggling in international term is
there a lot of different outside factors
that come into play and so here the
experience being one of them dojin has
had plenty of experience representing
his country outside of the Philippines
looking suppression is delicate with the
perfect to close out game one just
suffered a loss to kagemaru as well so
that's still weighing heavily on his
mind
yeah yeah dojin definitely hates the
song every time the song come nod he
just see it that's the last round I
don't think I've ever even heard this
song in the game what I don't even know
what song it's only when a lawyer says
that outfit on it switch around that's
why that's why I haven't heard yeah I'm
getting real close to the ear mm-hmm
that's why I hate it oh because keep
changing all these gauges song
I miss you mad Oh Jo here for the join
which is about it just slightly in the
topic getting started yeah and yet this
able to give tomorrow is even crazier
believers today not even the real
tournament this is not even a real turn
this is the realest there's no
tournament real event this and that's
right you don't really seem go for the
side switch command grab under that off
we carry bars has great wall carry yeah
I mean it's built into the tip the
stance right like just naturally so much
Oh wall pressure the wall splat the tap
is broken trade anyone game Oh dad no
words
let's go sometime oh no gin on port
still that much round isn't really face
good even back old air got the ground
texture two eyes but but he's also
experienced for so long I love in bars
yeah full circle you know that's kind of
lose somewhat the old for when he
started off set point now for with the
large king dominant to this is a guy
that emerged from the entire field of
the Pakistani players at the back result
he qualified earned the right to come
here so it's kind of cotton like the
whole country on his back everybody all
right hey working on a perfect he's
about to get crazy
oh that was a nice transition there was
about to get crazy you want to splat
he's got to do that like two more times
one more time oh my god John Dana life
is so close this is sort of a life on
the line now right is for the John
though like really
he's awake now he's been dodging time to
set point for dojin it's got to make
this count
I think if John wins it's got all the
break from dojin that down three-block
could have been everything through this
round getting off to a great start here
the patient now he's slowing it down
slow it down I'll allow them to punish
just a little bit more optimally this is
how you won the first game and first few
rounds here it just really slow really
calculated perfect spacing so combo
can't kill here on this small stage that
was not luckily all the back counter a
little bit too far at the wall what a
run back from the John who ties it up
one apiece final game incoming losers
we're actually making the top eight I
know though just not happy about getting
hit with that last hit there was no
reason for him to Crouch right there
with mardik going into Valley - no
there's no low that could have come out
from right to that moment it was really
no reason to get in there Wow Oh stretch
though not even trying to think about
maybe just really comfortable with the
stage on there once again that's the
first accessible
make the John's recognizing that Mike
you might just see a lot more taxes
around
counterweight our back for here gonna
burn it here with the wall by side one
time too many looks like John knows the
windows for when we can try to at least
go for some of these intervals yeah
nice lock nothing Oh beautifully the
better salvaged it at the end that is
not easy to do yeah Oh third run it
again yeah he was whoa don't do not
having it and that was a little bit
risky as well he was the wall beat to
his back last something went for to that
switched it up this time yeah of course
it only makes sense to try to test them
again attack would you write recalled it
watching what this guy's been doing
overseas this is more what you used to
problem is though just ducking for the
tackle round for better hate the song a
little bit less right now yeah set point
for the John here
make a move dojin's going in the tackles
are working out break a leg
even on health you know another one
every time he's ducking here right yep
the break extremely good block though
straight point it should be careful okay
that's it called it and the job could
have taken over dojin very very he's in
yeah that was down the white doughnut
had multiple opportunity closed it out
the John Doe state folk brought it back
composure so important that kind of
situation that's got to be a big
confidence booster for him that was
buried he found him I mean his back was
to the wall that's that's a game - yeah
it was actually the second time he
caught dojin with the wake up get up low
Tom Oates is sealed around and I think
that that was just something he had in
his pocket waited for the perfect moment
to take the round take a set price since
a little bit of desperation for those
you trying to the exact closing out too
quickly I know and he was also turning
the heat on - he was like dojin was
either gonna be all the way back all the
way in any kind of sense that dojin was
trying coming up next oh man they be
long we went up against tissue one it's
one of my personal favorites tissue
model my question for peel all character
selection we start running Akuma earlier
he's known for Brian but who do you up
against rated I think to be safe I think
you'll I would just go Google I think my
most comfortable with tournament the
Brian I'm not sure fees if he's gonna go
point but I mean I definitely personally
I would love to see his
I know I know Jimmy would love to see it
yeah I mean I noticed Montes quite
comfortable in Brian I've seen him run
games with Jimmy J Tran doing very well
at least two seasons ago you know it
does carry over somewhat and you know
Jimmy is the Brian that everybody looked
to say that that said we're gonna see
Brian vs. Raven Raven versus Puma
we see tissue Mon also quite approve all
the time him having epic battles with
Super Puma throughout the years of
course they're of course two different
styles yes first question for me is this
blog gonna land the combos he's gonna
like start off struggling with reactions
there to the crowd behind like what
happened no something happened back
there we are law vs. tishoo a tishoo
Mont - how does he get into position to
be able to try to work that often how
does he get up close cartwheel baby was
born start power crush take that back
three I'll take what's the best thing
you do Attica to get that back turn from
Raven oh you know just the fact that she
has a bacterial power crush move I heard
you got talking about it earlier like
usually when the characters back turn
you wanna do something like a low jab
just to get him out of the music they're
not able to stop that but you know it's
a 50/50 honestly because if you blocked
out you're gonna get some heavy point of
damage a sidewalk left is also a good
option to against a lot of our back turn
attack
I stopped fishing ponds all also been to
kind of a staple in the technical tour
finals as well for the past two years I
feel he use a last in addition right to
the telescope he is plan to come for
like a week ago
yeah yes they invite you after one of
the events in Europe when you didn't win
give me one of myself I don't want to
miss out something like man look at this
LCQ I got a nerd you need to be here and
if you're not you need to be here this
yeah no that's very true though
get these two or finals if it's ridicu
your back to the wall against equipment
like that two three it's like it's fun
so down for one string is so good
because you can't fuzzy and then the
down three compliments it that on the
other side and of course the special can
suppose do such high return that's how
you feel down back to flow to the wall
not gonna chop oh you need to can sit up
to get full wall damage yeah Raven bass
whoa no ultimate to hell what she had
all feed expressing like what the hell
just happened I was sick so you know as
a old man playing
[Laughter]
maybe have their Bible no way yeah look
out of full crouch other clothes out of
back turn em down back to what he's
gotta be use one meter I'll play him
this round though yeah County hit
jackknifed let's steal sweet instead
you've all start to pile on
she buns gotta be very careful here
especially with won't Baran be long side
don't want to run into a County hit 440
or anything like that it's back himself
up to the wall just get my CD oh that's
what come into play a lot sidewall
man the scrap or never these like it's
kind of unnecessary right my little
accidents the worst of luck will be the
stage here stage of choice for tissue
Mon maybe you don't yeah the only one
left
yeah probably some land a lot of rubble
[Laughter]
a lot of collateral damage along the way
I was I was trying to get on the LCQ bus
and the bus drove right past its range
Suites working out here will be low on
the mid-range just on you 5 - something
around petition bond for not breaking
not buckling yet
[Applause]
yeah whoa get up counter hit song it's a
delayed version of the getup - which is
throwing everybody off it looks like
he's standing up straight but he's
catching that very last second window -
kind of still have the way cupcake you
can either do mid or low the plan nice
got the duck down that back boy I'll
take this who's got a meter advantage
the first time we really see them get
that risky in this whole set
they just got Costabile mad he's one of
the last study players at the winner's
bracket man he's got to show up whatever
he can
trial with black hole I tried to get a
win one issue but he sidestepped but
didn't rely so scary everytime Akuma's
got a bar man gotta sit back we have one
clean hit is over back to to trying to
get in on his turn please
well I was gonna try to get in there
right now right now she's never afraid
man fight especially we back him into a
corner like this down two rounds one
zero in the set that's true I feel like
watching him in sets that's what he
really starts to pull out though is
gambits oh you saw that at all four
three two try to count back for you no
flaws had to play a very good ground
game here come out of the air somebody's
turtling up
Oh howdy jack night it's like it's gonna
kill or two three no pretty easy under
this oh goodness not like this
it's been getting hairy every time you
went for magic damage fix rings champ
just the clothes about two sheep on game
I'm trying to see a game three man hold
on trouble still sitting on a portal be
law gonna be the one movement on winners
side here top 16 he was still always
right there yeah that's what a fella I
don't know what to say how great of
matches right there for sure like Gannon
kagemaru are still a winner oh my god
John ding John D still a winner
I knew this John thing that's coming up
that's coming up that's it a played each
other what about buk buk buk what am i
yeah this is crazy
alright guys so I think we're almost
down to the top 16 we're gonna take a
short break before we get there don't go
anywhere grab a snack stuff and come
right back because Tom 16 is coming your
way in just a second